there is a litigation attorney that is
offering five thousand dollars to any
woman that can find her a husband she is
offering a five thousand dollar bonus
let's pull up the video Kim that's not
with my boss like a couple years ago
as friend her husband a couple other
s but I feel like I'm just gonna open it
up to the general public because I'm
good for it so the backslash offers if
you introduce me to my husband and I
marry him I will give you five thousand
dollars I don't have to stay married to
him for long I can get divorced in 20
years it doesn't matter but if you
introduce me to a man that I walk down
the aisle and get married to I will give
you five thousand dollars my DMs are
open
how she says I don't have to be married
to him for long this is the mindset
women want the wedding more than they
want the marriage she doesn't do you
hear that she doesn't even care about
being married to this man for long all
she wants is a husband